welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the Man of
Steel yo girl and I really need to work
on these intros more Batman V Superman
has just celebrated its fourth birthday
and whether you love or hate the movie
you have to admit it's still a big
talking point in the comic-book
community it really is the Marmite of
superhero films and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
some of the insane details that are
laced throughout the film we will be
going over the extended cut which in my
opinion is the superior version of the
movie after seeing the theatrical
version I remember leaving the cinema
feeling massively disappointed but the
ultimate edition remedies pretty much
all of the problems that I have with the
film and these tidbits make it that much
better obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you somehow haven't
managed to see the movie yet then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and with
that out of the way thank you for
cooking this now let's get into our
breakdown a Batman V Superman okay so
the movie opens with an almost flashback
like fantasy of Bruce Wayne as a young
boy falling into the Batcave and then
ascending upwards this is interlaced
with shots of the Wayne murder after
they just let the cinema whilst this
scene is predominantly to set up the
super Martha bros motif that unites The
Dark Knight in Man of Steel it also has
a number of things going on firstly
there's a poster for Zorro which is
traditionally the film that the Wayne's
went to see before that fateful night
however we can also see that Excalibur
too is playing at the theater this is
important as both films end in a similar
sort of way
Excalibur ends with King Arthur being
speared by Mordred and he pulls the
spear closer to himself so that he can
stab the villain this is similar to how
Superman is speared at the end and then
he drives Doomsday's core further into
himself so that he can kill the Beast
Martha is also a word used to carry a
lot of emotion throughout the movie and
the way that Thomas Wayne says it is
meant to mirror the way the horse and
Welles did in Sisson Kane both carry a
lot of meaning to Bruce and Charles
Foster Kane and the similarities of
these scenes show the direction that
Snyder was trying to take with it from
here we jump to the attack on metropolis
by Zod however this
Raun we see it's solely from Bruce's
perspective now hats off to the editor
here because if you play the two scenes
from both movies side-by-side they line
up completely it's an amazing continuity
detail that allows us to see the battle
from both the viewpoint of a superhuman
and a normal person watching Man of
Steel and bbs back to back really adds
to this and it gives to spare to the
destruction of the first film that made
it look like it was just a cool action
scene in this the world engine is
destroyed however that doesn't mean that
the horror of it doesn't stay with Bruce
long after every time he has a nightmare
the loud humming sound of the gigantic
machine can be heard and this symbolizes
that the characters suffers from PTSD
over it eagle-eyed viewers also noticed
a Man of Steel there was a poster in the
building that said keep calm and call
Batman this is of course what Jack does
as he calmly calls Bruce before dying I
absolutely loved that one shortly after
the attack we cut to two policemen
watching a football game between
metropolis and Gotham the latter team is
actually the one that Victor stone aka
cyborg plays for but he isn't mentioned
in the broadcast as this is after his
accident we also get a reference to the
watchman with graffiti saying the end is
nigh Rorschach used to carry this on a
sign and it ties together this movie
with Snyder's other comic book
adaptation Watchmen this isn't the only
Watchmen reference either as during the
fight between Batman and Superman we can
see graffiti that says and wait for it
because I'm gonna butcher it Kier's
custodiet Ipsos custodes terrible this
translates to who watches the Watchmen a
catchphrase from the film and graphic
novel the sword of Alexander which cut
the Gordian knot also appears later in
the film and this too is referenced in
Ozymandias and Watchmen to give an
example of lateral thinking the two
policemen are called to investigate 193
9 hop away their callsign is also Delta
Charlie 27 this is a reference to
Detective Comics 27 which was released
in 1939 and it featured the debut of
Batman much like how this scene does now
it's not too long after this that we are
introduced to Lex Luthor and he pretty
much instantly brings up his father who
throughout the film we learn was a cruel
man this is interesting because it
paints out one of the main themes in Man
of Steel and B
yes which is paternal relationships
mothers of cause play a big part as
indicated by the Martha scene but
fathers arguable play just as important
of a role a Man of Steel a Jonathan Kent
wish to hide clock and shield him from
the world until he was ready to make the
choice over whether to go public or not
he died protecting him and this too is
murdered in how Thomas protects Bruce's
a boy before he gets murdered both of
these fathers had a positive impact on
their children whereas Lex's father did
not even though Alexan Bruce both have
the exact same goal which is to destroy
Superman they both go about in different
ways because of their upbringing and the
way that their fathers tread them
because he suffered abuse at the hands
of his father
Lex has developed a hate for powerful
men he has used this hate as a drive to
become successful
however he realizes that he will never
be more powerful in Superman ease this
is why he will go to whatever ends he
can in order to bring the character down
we know that his father severely
mistreated him and this is exemplified
by the line no man in the sky intervene
when I was aboard to deliver me from
Daddy's fists and abominations now
what's ironic about this is that after
Lex creates doomsday the abomination it
goes to punch him
however Superman comes in and stops his
fist from hitting the character so a man
from the sky in the end it did come down
to deliver him from the fists of an
abomination before Lex is arrested at
the end of the movie he turns his
father's painting upside down to show
demons coming from the sky with angels
coming from the ground in retrospect
this actually ties into Justice League
in which parademons come down from the
sky and Superman and the Justice League
defend the planet lakhs of course
communicates with Steppenwolf at the end
and though his design differs slightly
from how it is in Justice League this
sets up a lot of things for the
following movie Lex manipulates Wallace
Keith play by scoot mcnairy into hating
Superman and we can also see a moment in
the film where he has a picture of
Superman lifting a car above his head
this is a reference of the first
appearance of the character and Action
Comics and which he did the exact same
thing
Lex also takes down Superman by twisting
the media and making the public distrust
him news reports pop up throughout the
film and the public perception of the
Man of Steel is weaponized against him
this is showcased in a scene that mirror
ism
and Man of Steel massively the first
time that it appears was when the army
were pointing their guns at Clark as he
landed whereas the second shot has
cameras in at that mirror the positions
of the guns another shot that is eerily
close to Man of Steel happens during the
day of the Dead festival in which
Superman saved someone the character is
surrounded by skulls at both points and
he could share the feeling that the
character is confused over whether he
can trust these people or not
in Man of Steel he couldn't trust Zod
even though they were both Kryptonian
and in BBS he has difficulty trusting
Humanity as they seem to hate him Batman
two grapples with his past we can also
see Robins uniform in the Batcave which
has the words jokes our new scrawled
across it this lets us know that Robin
was killed by the Joker and in Suicide
Squad we learn that Harley Quinn was
complicit in his death now people often
joke that Batman puts the bat symbol in
absolutely everything and is actually a
funny moment in BBS where this too can
be hinted at at one point during the
movie we see the lake which Bruce lives
beside the way this entire shot is
angled mirrors the bat symbol and it
shows the attention to detail that the
creative team had with the work after
the nightmare scene and flash
time-traveling we cutted the docks where
we get a reference to Jack Nicholson who
of course played the Joker in Batman
1989 we discovered that Martha works at
a diner and you may remember in the
first film that she worked in Sears this
was destroyed during a fight and nuts
she's had to change jobs before the
final battle
Superman confronts Lex and he sets a
timer for one hour this is actually
exactly one hour before the end of the
film and once more hats off to the
editors in the battle between Batman and
Superman Supes arrogantly catches a
grenade this then explodes in his face
and sprays kryptonite gas everywhere
which severely weakened sym earlier in
the movie he juice flew through
explosives as he didn't believe that
they could damage him Clark clearly
learns from this mistake though as in
justice league when cyborg fires a
missile at him he dodges out of the way
instead of letting it hit him in the
fight Bruce cuts clocks face with the
Kryptonite spear and this leaves him
with a scar the scar is there early on
when he's fighting doomsday and the two
eventually end up going into space where
they're fired upon the nuke explodes and
almost wipes him out and he heals
himself using the sir
this scar then disappears as he's fully
regenerated
now speaking of scars Domesday used to
be Zod and you can actually spot the
same scar on the left side of his face
the movie ends much in the same way that
it began with a shot of a coffin and it
shows that everything is come full
circle this is Superman's funeral and
actually pulls from the real-life
funeral of JFK which had a very similar
looking parade that Superman's funeral a
cannon is fired and we watched the shell
of it hit the floor in slow motion this
is similar to how we watch the bullet
from Joe chills gun land after killing
the Wayne's at the start of the movie
Superman's birth also mirrors his death
in these two shots we can see that there
is a ray of light coming in Batman
stands in the position of jor-el
Wonder Woman stands in the position of
quick qui liqueur wherever the Droid is
called and Lois is in the position of
Laura when jor-el dives into the water
to get the codec and Man of Steel this
moment is murdered in the young diver
earlier in BBS that finds the Kryptonite
rock Zod stabs jor-el similar to how
doomsday stabs Superman at the end of
the film and during the movie when
Superman is put on trial he walks down a
long corridor this shot is set up
exactly the same as it is in Man of
Steel when he's escorted by military
personnel Superman pulling the bow along
in the film is similar to Jesus carrying
the cross before his crucifixion and the
movie is laced with a ton of symbolism
that ties to the real world it's a
really great film that is filled to the
brim with amazing details and hopefully
this video has helped you to appreciate
it a bit more now obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the film so
comment below and let me know if you
know it's the anything that I didn't and
make sure you leave it to as I'd love to
see if there's any details that will
make me appreciate the movie more make
sure you check out our breakdown of
Joker which goes over some of the
craziest elements of that film and we
discussed the hidden countdown in the
background of scenes whether the movie
was a fantasy or not and the reason that
all the clocks are set to the same time
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]